hey league legals i thought i would take  a break from your regularly scheduled  programming to give you a sneak peek  of my new office as you can see it's  filled with many leather-bound books and  it smells of rich mahogany a couple of  eagle-eyed viewers  pun intended noticed that the books had  changed in my regular  shooting location and it's in locations  like this that i plan on shooting a  whole bunch of new videos  in 2021 and ramping up production and  speaking of which  only until january 1st can you get 41  off of curiosity stream and nebula where  i put extended versions of all of my  videos  so check that out and as always i'll see  you in court  or in this office